[Captions by Y Translator]
Guys, today, we're doing
something a little bit different.
We are here at Salt Lake FANX.
Previously known as Salt Lake Comic Con,
and today, we're going
to be looking around,
walking around checking out
some of the stuff that we have here
at this convention,
and we'll be sharing with you
some of the tips and tricks
that we've learned from going
to cons in the past that hopefully
could help you if you haven't gone
yet or even if you've been to several.
[Music]
First two tips to share
have to do with comfort.
One is for the comfort of others,
and one is for your comfort.
You may notice that there
are quite a few people here.
I'm pretty sure this convention gets
upwards of 70,000 people coming through,
and there are some
bigger Cons than that even.
So, the first tip is always make
sure you shower and wear deodorant.
It's going to make the day better for you.
It's going to make the day
better for everyone.
If that were not a thing,
like this would probably
the most unpleasant room in the world.
The second tip that I have for your
own comfort is to do what you can to
make sure you wear comfortable shoes.
Most convention centers will
either have a concrete floor,
or just a thin carpet going over it.
And if you walk around
for a long time on that,
your feet are definitely
going to start to hurt.
So good shoes, good soles.
You might even want to get the inserts
to make it even more padded.
It's going to make your day a lot better.
>> It's excellent.
>> For me?
>> Good job.
>> What are your gonna do with it?
Let's go do smashing things!
If you can, you might want to
try bringing in your own food.
Most conventions will let you
at least bring in some good snacks,
and if you get the food
that they're selling there,
it's usually pretty high priced.
So you can probably save
yourself some money, bring snacks in.
If they don't then even leaving
food in the car is probably
going to be a best bet for lunch.
[Music]
>> Oh, you got a marker.
That's so handy to have.
>> Very cool.
Osric Chau everyone.
>> Hey.
Thanks very much.
>> Builder, maker, creator, doing things.
We try to think of titles and like
labels for what he actually does,
and we can't because
he does so many things.
>> So what do you think?
You want to be in a video sometime?
>> Oh absolutely.
>> Awesome, we'll make that happen.
It's probably a good idea to use
the restroom before you
show up at the con.
Sometimes it's nice and organized
and there's no problem getting
in, but a lot of the time there's going to
be a lot of people and the lines will be
pretty crazy long
and cleanliness is iffy.
So, it can't hurt to use
the loo before you go.
Just make your life easier.
Comic conventions are a really cool
place to wear your favorite costume
or cosplay but you do want to make
sure that the first time you wear it
is not while you're at the convention.
You want to try and spend at least
a couple of hours wearing your costume
before the convention so that you'll
know where it may or may not be
comfortable, if it pinches, if it
binds or especially if it's
going to break or tear anywhere.
If you do have problems with it breaking,
you want to make sure you reinforce
that before you get to the convention.
[Music]
It's a really good idea
at conventions to always bring cash.
A lot of vendors do take cards
but sometimes their card readers
go down or sometimes they just
don't have them and you should also
make sure that you have small bills.
Sometimes it's hard to
have change for stuff.
So bring cash, use small bills
and then save yourself having
to pay the like, $5 at ATM fees.
It's pretty nuts.
[Music]
>> How many millions
of followers you have?
>> We just passed ten million.
>> Ten million idiots follow this guy.
Can you believe that?
I got 37 people who follow me.
You got ten million.
>> How many people saw you
in Guardians of the Galaxy though?
>> 20, 20 people saw me.
This is the monger taking
revenge on the maker.
Ready?
>> It's what happens.
>> It happened. This is really look great.
>> You know what?
If you need something built,
if you let me know.
I can get that done for you.
>> That's right man,
he does that for a living.
>> He builds [bleep]
Ten million followers.
If you follow him it will
be ten million and one.
>> Thanks very much.
All right. Well that was
completely unexpected.
I literally didn't even realize
he was there until we like stopped and
he was like, oh yeah, the the hammer.
He actually signed that earlier.
We were just talking about it.
He thought it was cool and was like,
can I sign this, and so he signed it.
That was great.
[Music]
I'm a Ravenclaw.
There are a few items that
I would definitely recommend
you bring to a con with you.
I've got this backpack
that was super cheap,
and I love it
because it weighs like nothing.
This whole backpack is like, maybe
a quarter of a pound, probably less,
like it is so light and thin
but it holds plenty for me,
and then there's several things that
I like to fill this back with every time.
First off, I like to have a water bottle.
Usually there's going to be
drinking fountains,
and drinks around you can
get for the water bottle's nice.
If you can't bring it in full,
then just fill it up a drinking fountain
first chance you get and then
whenever you just start get dehydrated,
overheated, anything like that,
you've got water with you.
I talked a little bit about how you
want to bring food and maybe some snacks.
I really like to just bring in
some high energy protein bars,
energy bars, something like that.
They have a fair number of pretty
healthy calories, that keep you going
for a while without taking up much space.
Without making you
feel too heavy and full.
A little bit of fresh
fruit is never a bad idea.
I love apples.
That's what I'm going with.
I have a permanent marker.
You never know when you're gonna
run into someone, if you're ever gonna
want to sign stuff and just in case
they don't have anything on them.
You've got it covered.
>> Oh, you've got a marker
that's so handy to have.
>> Hand sanitizer or some wet wipes.
I think these things are great.
There are a lot of germs flying around
at a convention that's going to happen
when you've got lots of people,
and especially if you're
about to eat something.
It's really nice to make sure your
hands are going to be nice and clean.
So you're not just getting
those germs right into your face.
No one wants to get sick.
Phone charger.
This is a spare battery.
This has enough battery power to
fill my phone up like three times.
It wasn't very expensive.
It's not very heavy.
Fits in my pack and I never have
to worry about my phone going dead.
Finally, a spare pair of socks.
You walk around your feet can get
kind of sweaty and gross.
I like to have an extra pair of socks
for if that happens and then I put them
in a plastic bag so that I have
somewhere to put my
gross socks in afterwards.
And then of course,
I am carrying around a backpack
that has some space in it.
So if I pick up a souvenir, I've got
somewhere where I can just carry it
around, don't have to worry about it.
You might have other stuff that you
always like to carry around.
Let us know if you've got something
cool you think would help other people.
Cons are a lot of fun.
Hopefully some of these tips
and tricks will be useful for you
whether you've been
to no cons before or 50.
There's always more to learn
and if you've got any cool tips
and tricks you want to share
let us know down in the comments.
Guys, we've always got
more for you to see.
That box off the top will take you to our
last video, you should check that out,
and the box at the bottom will
show you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next.
And if you're not a subscriber just
hit this bomb to get in the club.
That way you'll never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.